>> Okay, so what else can my
23andM report tell me besides ancestry information?
>> Well, one thing that I'd like to go and look at
next is to see what your DNA says about some of your traits.
>> Okay. So where am I going to go to look at my traits?
>> All right, so go up to My Results menu.
>> Okay.
>> And under there you'll see Traits and just click on the Traits. All right.
>> Oh, cool.
>> So here's a long list of traits,
but as an example what I'd like to
focus on first is the report on lactose intolerance.
>> Okay.
>> and here's a column with stars and that, the
number of stars there reflects how strong the science behind the report is. Not,
not, not so much, you know, your particular result, but how if,
if the scientific literature is really
supportive of, of the connection between DNA
and, and the trait. Okay, scrolling down it looks
[INAUDIBLE].
>> So lactose intolerance
>> So there's some background here on
lactose intolerance and then here are your results.
>> It says I'm likely to be tolerant.
>> Yes.
>> Due to lactase persistence and.
>> So you have your're homozygous for the A allele.
>> Okay.
>> that's the critical SNV here and you share that with your dad.
Your dad also has two copies of the A, so this means you got an
A from your dad and an A from your mother. and having two copies there
is, is making it most likely, according
to the scientific literature, that you are going
to be tolerant of lactose and able to drink, continue to drink milk as an adult.
>> I see and I notice here too that I'll be lactose tolerant
because I'm lactase persistent. And it looks like even if I
have only one A then I'm still lactase persistent, so can
you tell us if the A allele promotes lactase persistence even
in the heterozygous state. Is the A allele dominant or recessive?